what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
8 plot league video
today i will be reading season 8 episode
5. and instead of wasting any time
let's just get right into it the opening
scene begins with melisandre kinvara and
varys traveling by land
they are leading an enormous party of
over 25 000 soldiers
melisandre and kanvara were able to
bring a thousand soldiers of their own
along with several thousand followers of
relore they are followed by theon
yara and the commander of the golden
company behind them are several thousand
ironborn men
plus twenty thousand soldiers from the
golden company they were able to get
enough dragonglass to fill a wagon but
there is not enough to arm them all
melisandre and kinvara finally find the
location where they plan on setting up
camp
while they wait for jon daenerys and the
others to arrive
some of the followers of verlor begin to
make several massive bonfires alongside
the river
melisandre and kanvara begin chanting
different prayers to the fires and
everyone who watches
they talk about the long night and the
one who will bring the dawn
they talk about the great other in the
lord of light and they finish by saying
the night is dark and full of terrors
but tonight those terrors will be
extinguished varys is very unsettled by
melisandre and kinvara
as the day grows dark the rubies on
their throats continue to glow brighter
after all the prayers and the chanting
dies down kinvara walks over to speak
with varys
kanvara asks varys if he was looking
into the flames as they said their
prayers
she says would you like me to show you
the answers that the lord of light has
given us
varys can barely make eye contact with
kinvara
kinvara leans in close to varys and she
begins to whisper
she says there will be a great battle
here tonight
and we all have our own part to play
almost every single person you see
standing here will die tonight
we all must make our own sacrifices i
will die tonight
melisandre will die tonight and you
varys
will die tonight the lord of light has
given us protection
but now we must protect him the next
scene is in king's landing
there are several people gathered inside
a big hall qyburn and euron are standing
at the top of the steps on a large
platform
after a few moments cersei walks in with
her escort the mountain
cersei is wearing a black gown with
golden trim
on the back of the gown there is a line
and a kraken stitched into it
next to euron is a pillow with two brand
new crowns displaying the lion and the
kraken on them
made of solid gold now that cersei has
given up any shred of faith she might
have had
she now has her hand of the king qyburn
marry her and euron
afterwards euron places the new crown on
cersei's head
and cersei places a new crown on euron's
head
making him her king there is no feast
no music or betting ceremony since
cersei is still recovering from the
miscarriage
instead they go outside to check up on
all of king's landings defenses
all of the lannister soldiers are now
staying inside of their walls
more pitch and wildfire is being brought
up and placed near each gate that enters
the city
more barrels filled with steel arrows
are being placed beside
each ballista there are now over a dozen
ballistas aiming at the sky
qyburn walks up to euron and cersei and
he tells them
the final phase is complete in the next
scene john and daenerys are flying
further south on dragon and regal
before they left white harbor bran said
they must go to the trident
but he hasn't said exactly where they
should land that's until they spot a
massive force making camp
they can also see several large fires
burning into the night sky
when they approach the camp bran signals
to john that this
is the place this is where they must
land after they land the dragons
daenerys is first greeted by varys
who is accompanied by the commander of
the golden company varys introduces the
commander to daenerys and john
and they can't believe that varys was
able to pull this off they assumed
varys had fled the north to protect his
own ass this couldn't have came at a
better time
because the only people to make it out
of winterfell alive
are the ones who landed on the dragons
theon also tells jon and daenerys that
he has most of euron's fleet
along with several thousand men of the
ironborn ready to swear fealty and help
them defeat the army of the dead
daenerys gives yara a hug and she tells
her that she's sorry for what has
happened to her
and she swears that once they finish the
night king they will kill
cersei lannister and euron greyjoy next
varys tells john and daenerys about
melisandre and kinvara being here
with thousands of followers of her lore
and he says they made him come with them
or else he would have went north he also
tells them
what kinvara said about almost everyone
dying here tonight
and john doesn't like what he is hearing
especially since he found out melisandre
was burning people alive
including princess shireen jon tells
daenerys that he needs to go speak with
melisandre at once
he wants to keep her and davos away from
each other until he can figure
everything out
jon doesn't want a war to break out and
men die before the night king arrives
jon walks over to the fires and
melisandre and kinvara are surrounded by
several soldiers all dressed in red
john notices the ruby and melisandre's
necklace is glowing brighter than he's
ever seen it before
when melisandre sees jon she decides to
approach him before he can say anything
in front of the others
john says what are you doing here i told
you to
but melisandre cuts him off melisandre
says i know what you told me
but you need me now more than ever
darkness will be upon us soon
and i told you i could help you defeat
the night king that time has come
there is no more running from this we
will all dance amongst the fires tonight
melisandre says there will be a great
sacrifice here tonight jon snow
i have seen it in the flames and it must
be done she also says do you know what
the night king wants
do you know why he is coming here
tonight the fires behind melisandre
begin to burn harder
and higher the ruby on her neck begins
to shine even brighter
and she says the night king is coming
for his replacement
the one who was chosen is amongst us now
and he will not stop until he gets what
he has came for
melisandre begins to raise her voice we
must give his replacement to the fire
jon snow
the great other is here and we must put
an end to all the terrors in the
darkness
melisandre's voice begins to get so loud
that it draws the attention of everyone
in the camp
people begin to gather around jon and
melisandre she continues to say we must
give him to the fire jon snow
we must make this great sacrifice then
everyone from john's party is watching
including arya gendry and davos the
tension is beginning to rise throughout
the crowd
the fires continue to get brighter and
hotter and her ruby is getting so
bright that some people in the crowd
have to turn their eyes away from it
davos tells jon that melisandre
shouldn't be here
she is evil along with everyone that is
chanting along with her
all of a sudden melisandre stops
speaking and the chanting stops
the 25 000 people gathered near the
fires are completely silent
melisandre has noticed something in the
crowd of people but no one is quite sure
who she is looking at
that's until melisandre sticks out her
hand and she points
melisandre is pointing at gilly and
little sam and when davos realizes what
she is insinuating
he pulls arya's dagger right off of her
hip and he lunges from alessandra
jon struggles to hold him back as davos
begins to scream
he says melisandre has already burned
one little girl alive
he will not sit by and watch her burn
someone else's child
melisandre says it is the only way you
must bring me that child
the lord of light has shown me a great
sacrifice in the flames
and i am his instrument arya stark then
pulls out needle
she is prepared to kill melisandre
herself gendry also has his warhammer in
hand
they're not gonna allow melisandre to
get her hands on little sam
then bran stark moves himself closer to
the fire
and bran finally speaks and he says
melisandre is right
there will be a great sacrifice here
tonight i have also seen that child
surrounded by fires in my visions
bran then looks to gilly and says your
son was meant
as an offering to the night king he was
going to be the final sacrifice
bran moves closer to gilly and he tells
her he has seen all of this in his
visions
he tells her that her son is more
special than she knows
craster's sons were offerings to the
night king they became the night king's
personal king's guard
but little sam was meant to be more than
that little sam was going to be the
100th offering
and he was going to become the next
night king the night king needs newborns
as his instruments
and they all need to come from a special
bloodline gilly's father
and son has the blood of the dragon
craster's father wasn't just an ordinary
man of the night's watch
he had the blood of the targaryens bran
then turns to melisandre and john
and he says melisandre said there would
be a great sacrifice here tonight
she is right i have seen that in my
visions jon
but it won't be her son melisandre you
will be that great sacrifice
you are the lady in red that i have seen
on the battlefield as bran is saying
this clouds start to move in above them
jon notices and knows what this means
the night king is bringing the storm
john yells for everyone to arm
themselves bran says jon i have told you
there is power in you that you must
embrace
i need you to trust me you must kill
melisandre if you want to stop the night
king
you must bring the dawn the fires
continue to get brighter
and melisandre's ruby is getting so hot
that steam is beginning to rise off of
it
davos says she killed princess shireen
and she was gonna kill gilly's son
and gendry starts yelling he says
melisandre was going to kill him too
the storm above them is growing larger
and snow is starting to fall into the
fires
kinvara begins chanting to the lord of
light she says they will make the great
sacrifice that he needs
bran davos gendry and arya are all
telling jon to kill melisandre
and finally melisandre drops to her
knees
when melisandre's knees hit the ground
viserion's scream echoes across the
battlefield
the night king is here sam walks over to
john and he pulls out his family's
ancestral valyrian steel sword
sam says melisandre wanted to murder my
son
i want you to use my sword it's called
heartsbane
plunge this into her evil heart hurry
you don't have much time without even
reacting
jon grabs the sword and plunges it deep
into melisandre's chest
smoke begins to roll out of melisandre's
nose and mouth
the ruby on her neck glow so bright that
it bursts into a red liquid that
completely covers the sword
turning it into the red sword of heroes
when jon pulls out the sword
it starts to glow red everyone begins to
run into position
thousands of men are scrambling to grab
their weapons
daenerys mounts drogon john pulls out
longclaw and he tosses it to jorah
mormont without
saying a word jorah jaime braun the
hound arya gendry barrick berean
and all the others have their weapons
drawn they begin to see
thousands of blue eyes glowing through
the storm
wolves begin to howl in the distance it
causes
arya to turn her head to see where it
was coming from
jon then mounts rhaegal with the glowing
red sword in his hand
the night king breaks to the storm
flying faster than anyone has ever seen
viserion swoops over the golden company
and torches hundreds of men in one
strike
daenerys and jon immediately take to the
sky jon signals for daenerys to take out
his army
while jon goes after the night king the
night sky begins to light up with bright
colors of blue
and red thousands are dying with each
pass of the dragons
there are two dozen white walkers
leading the army
half of them are armed with ice spears
as are the two giants
jorah jaime braun barrick the hound arya
gendry
and brienne all head for the white
walkers there will be an epic battle
where seven main characters fight close
to a dozen white walkers at the same
time
gendry smashes one right in the face
with his warhammer
arya stabs one in the side of the neck
with her dagger
and jorah kills one while saving breanne
after she fell from her injured leg
jaime lannister gets disarmed by one of
the white walkers and his sword falls to
the ground
brawn picks it up and he kills the white
walker for jaime
braun smiles at jaime then he tosses him
back his sword
and braun says if you drop the bloody
thing again i will be taking it with me
every time a white walker dies hundreds
of whites fall to the ground the
commander of the golden company has
one ballista in the back of the camp the
commander takes a long sharp piece of
dragonglass and fires it at one of the
giants
it hits the giant right in the chest and
it falls
he tries hitting visery on but he's
moving too fast to get a clear
shot at some point during the battle
jorah mormont sees a white walker taking
aim at drogon with a nice spear
jorah charges at the white walker and
disarms him but he gets swarmed by the
whites
and jaime kills the white walker by
shoving his sword into his back
barrack dondarrion uses himself as his
shield as another white walker tries to
kill the hound
daenerys burns both of the remaining
giants and she torches
thousands of whites the whole encampment
is now being swarmed by the remaining
whites
it forces the group to fall back john
takes aim at viserion
and regal lets lose his flame but it
doesn't seem to affect vasarion
one of the white walkers hits regal with
a nice beer causing him to spiral out of
control
the injury forces rhaegal to land and
jon has to continue on foot
with the glowing sword in his hand
everyone realizes they need to kill the
cerion as soon as possible
so the group begins to fall back even
further to where the ballista is
they are all taking several shots at him
but keep missing
finally braun is able to hit viserion
with a shard of dragonglass
but is not able to penetrate the dragon
he fires again
and again but the brittle dragonglass
isn't piercing viserion
then arya tosses brawn her valyrian
steel dagger to use as a projectile
it's small enough to slide down the
ballista and fire
braun takes aim and launches the dagger
it hits viserion right in the center of
his chest
viserion lets out a thunderous scream
and begins to fall like a rock from the
sky
the dragon slams into the ground and the
night king rolls off of him
into the snow the night king stands up
and pulls a curved ice sword out that
was strapped to his back
the night king looks over at viserion
and the dragon's eyes are closed
jon can see daenerys coming back around
on drogon he waves his glowing sword in
the air and signals to daenerys to land
jon wants to challenge the night king
one verse one
every man in white comes to a standstill
on the battlefield
with all of their eyes on jon and the
night king they begin to walk to each
other
and they never take their eyes off each
other they both walk until there is
about 15 feet in between them
the night king is holding his ice sword
and jon is holding the red sword of
heroes
after a few moments the battle begins
they are just a few feet away from each
other
and they are both moving around trying
to size the other one up before they
commit
and possibly expose themselves jon takes
a swing at his head
but the night king moves faster and is
more agile than the white walkers
jon missed by several feet the night
king takes a swing at jon
and jon almost loses his footing but he
recovers quickly
jon looks down and he notices the sword
cut through his fur
and leather the night king swings again
and this time he hits his mark
the ice cuts and burns into jon's arm
causing him to hold the sword with his
other hand
jon grips the handle hard and swings
fast like the snap of a whip
the night king raises his sword to block
the shot but the red sword cuts right
through the ice
and into the night king as the sword
comes out the other side
the night king shatters into thousands
of pieces
and his army explodes simultaneously
wolves
in the distance begin to howl and john's
red sword is steaming with water
dripping off of it
everyone watching was holding their
breath but they all let out a sigh of
relief
the snow stops falling and the clouds
above begin to break apart
the red glow of the sword begins to dim
daenerys begins to feel her baby moving
inside of her stomach
john walks over and he embraces daenerys
in front of everyone
then he embraces his family as light
begins to appear through the clouds they
all start to walk across the battlefield
it's nothing but death and devastation
all around them
john tells daenerys they must go to
king's landing next
they talked to the commander of the
golden company to find out about the
city's defenses
the commander tells them about the
ballistas and the wildfire placed at
each gate
they know they don't have the numbers to
breach the gate and it will be extremely
dangerous to fly in with all the
ballistas
jamie and tyrion say if they can get
them inside of the walls they can get
them into the red keep
there are several secret ways to enter
and exit
so they load up everyone that can be
useful for the mission the final scene
will be in king's landing
cersei euron and qyburn are discussing
their tactics
in case of a surprise attack cersei
tells qyburn that if the city is about
to fall
he needs to make sure the candles are
lit near the wildfire
cersei has no plans of surrendering or
fleeing the city
she intends on blowing everything up if
the walls are breached
qyburn has placed a wildfire under most
of the city
but the majority is under the red keep
there are hundreds of parts in the
lowest levels of the cells
after they discuss their plans cersei
tells qyburn to leave them while she has
a word with euron alone
jon and daenerys land the dragons a few
miles away from the city
they land at dusk but once it's dark
enough they planned on sending arya and
jaime ahead first
arya used to chase cats all over the red
keep and she once chased them down to
where the dragon skulls are kept
and she got lost trying to find her way
out she followed a storm drain that
emptied into the blackwater bay
so they're gonna take a small boat from
a village then head into the bay
and once they are there arya and jaime
will enter the storm drain and find
their way inside of the red keep
once they are inside arya will steal a
face from one of the guards while jaime
looks for cersei or euron
once arya has a face from a guard she
will then go kill as many people as
possible that are manning the ballistas
and hopefully open one of the gates to
let the others inside
jaime and arya prepare to head for the
shoreline to find a small boat
jaime is stopped by braun and braun
hands him the small dagger he always
keeps tucked behind his back
he tells jaime he will be in close
quarters inside the red keep
and it will be much easier to pull a
dagger than his sword
besides you can't hold on to the damn
thing anyhow they find a small boat soon
enough
and they slowly make their way into the
bay and once they hit the shore
they pull the boat onto the rocks and
they enter the storm drain
it takes them about an hour to find
their way through the dark but they find
themselves inside of the dungeons of the
red keep
this is where arya and jaime will head
their separate ways
arya slips outside the red keep and it's
not long before she kills a guard and
wears his face and uniform
she heads straight for the wall where
the main defenses are and arya is not
only light on her feet
but she's also very quick she crouches
down along the top of the wall
and begins slitting the throats of
everyone posted beside the ballistas
there are roughly a dozen of them spaced
out so she has to take her time to avoid
detection
someone eventually spots one of the dead
bodies and they sound the alarm
this is john and danny's signal that
it's time to move to plan b
storm the walls with the dragons
daenerys and john want to burn all the
ballistas first
then blow out a section of the wall to
allow the rest of their men into the
city
they both fly right over top of the red
keep and begin to torch the top of the
wall that protects the inner city
jaime can hear the chaos erupting
outside so he knows he must
act fast the lannister men end up
getting a few shots off from the
ballista
but it's not that easy to hit a moving
target at night arya disguised as a
guard
kills them too jon and daenerys both
torch a portion of the wall
and it eventually crumbles into a pile
of rubble john lands and lets the rest
of the men inside the blown out hole
out of an act of desperation cersei
orders the mountain outside
he's not to allow anyone inside of the
red keep then cersei signals for qyburn
to prepare to light the wildfire
down in the cells she is not prepared to
let her city fall while she's still
alive
euron leaves to help qyburn see it
through but in reality he's planning on
escaping the city and leaving cersei to
her own demise
jaime sees the mountain walking down the
stairs so he hides until he passes then
jaime climbs the steps
as jaime goes around the corner he sees
qyburn and euron walk
out of the room so jaime pulls his
dagger and he hides right around the
corner
the hound eventually spots his brother
outside the mountain is walking atop the
wall burning the parts of wildfire
stashed at every post
the hound finds his way up and
challenges his brother to one verse one
combat
the mountain sets down the torch and the
fight begins
an epic sword fight will ensue but the
hound is still no match for his bigger
and stronger brother
at some point during the fight the hound
and the mountain both lose their swords
and begin to fistfight
but the hound is barely denting his
armor the hound will eventually smash a
pot of wildfire over the mountain's
helmet
which knocks him to the ground then he
picks up his torch and tosses it on his
brother
cooking him inside of his armor qyburn
and euron come around the corner and
jaime shoves
the dagger into qyburn's throat all the
way down to the handle
euron is caught completely off guard but
he manages to grab jaime and take him to
the ground
an intense struggle between the two will
last for several minutes
until jaime manages to knock out euron's
teeth with his golden hand
then he pulls the dagger from qyburn's
throat and plunges it deep into euron's
chest
jaime leaves the dagger in his chest and
he begins to walk to cersei's chambers
next
jaime enters her chambers and cersei
can't believe her eyes
jaime was the last person she expected
to see cersei can see the blood on his
hands
and cersei begins to cry out to jaime
telling him how much she loves him
and how thankful she is to have him here
at this time she starts to touch her
stomach telling him how she has his
child
inside of her and jaime doesn't say
anything at first
he allows cersei to embrace him and his
eyes begin to fill up with tears
jaime looks at cersei and he tells her
that he loves her
and he even gives her a kiss on the
forehead and cersei begins to cry
cersei says she knew he would come back
and save her
and she leans in to kiss him on the lips
but before their lips can touch
cersei starts gasping for air jaime has
both hands on her throat
his left hand is squeezing as tight as
he possibly can
while he is applying pressure and
pushing down with the golden hand
cersei falls down to the floor and jaime
moves with her
he is on top of her still squeezing and
pushing tears start to roll down his
cheek as cersei struggles for air
until her body finally starts to stop
moving as cersei's eyes begin to slowly
close
the scene will fade to black and the
episode will end with the reigns of
castamere playing in the back
all right folks that was season 8
episode 5. this was a really big episode
with a lot of different things happening
so let me know what you think about this
one
put all your thoughts and questions down
below i'm really anxious to see what you
have to say about this episode
i want to thank everyone for stopping by
to watch the video and i really want to
give a special
shout out to all of my patreon
supporters the amount of new support
i've been getting over the past
10 days or so has been incredible thank
you all so much
i hope everyone has a great day and i
will see you back here for the finale
bye
[Music]
do
do
[Music]
[Music]
you